and all the viewers hey I see you're
working out man hey keep it up I'm like
wow thank you you know what I mean it's
like people I don't even know man but
they're just compliment congratulating
me telling me that you have your whole
life ahead of you like wow I'm down you
man
sheesh all right spooky so tell me
what's going on in your life it's been a
long time since you've been here man so
far so good I just want to thank God for
another day you know
um from previous to present as we speak
today
you know uh I have been in South
Central uh about maybe a year and a half
ago my uncle in South Central he passed
away recently so when the homeowners
came uh the people of the managers came
in there to you know oh yeah your
uncle's deceased what he goes yeah he
passed away so I'm not on the list so
automatically you got to go like oh so
as we begin a journey to you know South
Central without my uncle just been
living wherever I can rest my head at
without no BS over my head or or you
can't be right here or tent
or excuse me you're in a tent um no um
first we were in a a truck a truck that
was a A gde in the back laying in it
when the project was empty lot the tring
came in to you know do all the grass
chuck had to go outside when Chuck went
outside cops pulled us over hey um is
this yours truck no no it's not tell you
what um this is someone's truck it's a
g- ride since we know that you're living
right here next door to this duplex get
all your stuff and get a to truck and
it's going to be to away thank you sir
took everything out tow truck I me the
tow truck took the truck truck away and
my lady her name is
Linda uh it was a Sten G right but my
lady didn't know nothing about it so she
was working
for a boss named Mr ball which was uh
four
units back unit was burned down so he
asked her to watch this property so we
were in the middle unit and comfortable
sit once they find out oh there's a
essay bald head with tattoos oh makes
her look bad hey you know I thought I I
only want you to you know live there not
not you and your man so now now she has
to leave and it's all lot of BS but we
have gradually went from one place to
one place to one place to one place just
to you know bouncing around finally we
got stabled right here in downtown on
16th Street by the metro bus station and
uh you're you're in a motor home or um
RV RV RV uh 28 foot RV it's very nice uh
my lady got it towed from Ballwin Hills
to South Central and from South Central
to 16th Street Four Towers is like uh
two tires put together four tires blown
out it completely don't run she got
toilet over there and she wants to sell
it but it's like who wants to buy this
baby cu it's like four tires you know
then the battery is no good and they put
a lot of money plus a gasoline you know
what I mean so it's like you know let's
be thankful that we have a roof overhead
and we're okay plus we have a Dodge R
van
2001 battery went dead I went to go
change a battery put the cables
backwards it blew a black fuse smoke was
coming out oh [__] you know what I mean
I like okay call the mechanic they make
more trouble and now we're like we have
no running van I'm like oh man it's like
you know what what else can go wrong so
basically we're just staed right there
on 16th Street and my lady Tweety she
was
telling me that I have my son that's a
little more further down his name's Jun
Jun I said oh yeah yeah I know your son
you know but he's with an olderly outer
lady you know I know in Jun he was down
12 13 years old but this girl is a
little more older than him to this day
she's 45 and he's 17 like what the hell
whatever you know what I mean but you
know it's his life it's who he chooses
to love but her ex-husband lives in
front of them which my lady want to go
see her son are you hungry you need some
money here you go Mi you know but she's
a little oh get it to my mom you know
what does she want now like girl what is
your problem that's that's her son you
know like you know let Mom take nurture
her boy and take care of her boy I mean
whatever you know me but she had a
badass attitude and then when she told
me she was like oh her ex-husband I went
over see my son he had a ban in his hand
get it hey key hey is my son here no no
no no get out of here okay okay hey
don't need a shet chip when she told me
the message I said what he put a bat to
you and verbally like like trying to
like you know whack you like trying to
scare me okay so I go walking over
there and the guy was right there hey
get there I go come here homie I go hey
um if you ever ever pull a bat to my
wife ah get into SP who's your don't
worry about it homie if you ever my wife
again homie shut the [__] up homie homie
if you ever thre my wife I will [__]
kill you oh no no talk him over here who
is she who is she he's talking so much I
hit him one time with my left F foul
down by the black fence I guess his
girlfriend comes I get I said like [__]
you you know I mean and I kept on
pushing I go tell my lady honey um you
might want to text your son cuz um I
suck that guy the one that Tred to
threaten you what I had blood on my hand
and she goes oh my God I say well I mean
babe I said don't trip don't trip but
I'm thinking he's going to go cry to
your son's exwife that whatever whatever
whatever and as soon as she decided to
text him on messenger Mom hey M I jumped
in hey uh Jun Jun there might be someone
on your window telling you hey hey hey
some
what do you mean Spooks I knocked out
this guy named
man what I knocked him out he might be
coming out your window crying to you
guys oh hey you [__] up Spooks click I
looked at my I looked at my lady tweeted
like I [__] up okay it's your son's 17
I [__] up okay I might see be like oh
my God I'm scared well I mean whatever
next thing you know her and I are in the
RV I step out one of the other Audi
neighbors next to us was talking to us
he goes hey uh someone's coming over
here I go hold on babe I look outside
hey your son's coming her son comes with
his girlfriend and her
ex-husband her son's girlfriend's on the
far left hand side with a taser her
ex-husband's in the Middle with a
[__] samurai sword that you can split
in half and you can [__] have two
[__] little you know medium daggers
and like chop sooi whatever and her son
junju is with a
bat okay I got me a [__] Chrome um
chrome caressa wrench with a red
handle let alone I'm a to Striker if I
want to defend myself whack this [__]
in the head she falls down ambulance
pick her up I get handcuffed hit him in
the head crack a skull I'm [__] either
way so what do you want me to do get
tasered chop sooie hit with the bat I'm
okay Officer I'm okay okay yeah yeah and
then don't you know what I mean it was
just like I'm the one going to get
[__] I can say oh stop the fence I'm
[__] no matter what so the guy in the
Middle with the samurai SS he was doing
[__] Yoshi Noya chop sui he couldn't
get to me cuz I had the thing long
enough to keep my extent but when he got
mad he threw one of them he threw one of
them I went this and sliced my eyebrow
boom bar just nicked me but it was so
sharp it cut me and the second one he
had in his hand he threw it boom just
scraped my [__] neck and took a
little piece of [__] skin off and I
just
leaking they end up backing
up they end up taking off my girl goes
babe you're bleeding I'm like hey uh I'm
good I'm good oh my God don't trip
ambulance fire
department police come like damn want to
go to the hospital n I'm straight my
girl can't really be in the dark by
herself cuz she gets a little
paranoid he um from experience I don't
know how you know I mean it's so sharp
so quick you know I don't know how does
it hurt when you swallow I go it just
you know when I talk it just pulls a
muscle he goes yeah um yeah you got to
get that checked out and I told the
ambulance they put me on a tablet talk
to a doctor at um at a San Pedro
hospital and they were like sir how are
you feel right now I'm I'm okay just a
little sore throat you know when I
swallow but are you sure okay okay um if
you have any other like you can't
breathe or you Happ to fall asleep and
and you know uh you know can't breathe
and you want to start throwing up or
whatever come down as soon as possible
so we can take a look at it but um other
than that if you're okay then you know
hey you know we're right here I says
thank you and one of the ambulance says
let me give you a butterfly put two
butterflies snapped it took pictures
made a report okay got a report as I
think I didn't go to the hospital I'm in
the RV she's like up up and then she
falls asleep I'm in my mind like
retaliation I can't go to sleep so I'm
going to wait for the come back and I'm
waiting and waiting and waiting and
waiting like she's known for burning RVs
down oh come on girl where you at
nothing happens she's knocked out I
decide okay let me just lay back a
little bit I lay back oh no no no my
whole body goes back like
oh so I had to sit up the whole night
keeping G thinking for retaliation she's
knocked out I'm like oh my God this is
crazy as the days goes on you know what
I mean I'm kind of healing but as for
detectives hey Daniel we gave you a call
but you didn't answer the phone hey um
has youever been in retaliation since
the previous times and this and this I
am looking at the text message couldn't
get a hold of me the people that did
this to me are right down the street
like damn six RVs down they ain't going
nowhere they're right there and I'm
like okay so if I use my retaliation if
I go set forth and make my point across
I'm [__] not them me
okay and it's like they're still there
they don't get [__] with they don't
get
arrested my life almost got killed and
then L's like just give a time babe I'm
like give it time for what I mean you
know do your job you get it's almost
like just basically saying like you know
hey my life's on the line here I'm lucky
to be alive but yet you guys let these
people still R the streets I am like you
know what it's all good my lady tells me
she goes hey um my son came to me
recently and just apologized to me
apologize to you for what I mean that's
your little boy don't get me wrong but
I'm the one that almost got my life
tooken
but you know it's it is what it is but
you get tired of this life you been you
you been you've been on the streets most
of your adult life right most likely
sick and tired of being sick and
tired you don't look for trouble but
Trouble Follows you you don't startop no
[__] but [__] comes to you like do I
want my twe on my thumbs like okay go
ahead hit me
and then hit me officer I didn't do
nothing oh yeah two strier yeah oh come
on like what the it's it's so sad
because any violence that I do to
anybody to a man or a woman and they're
knocked down an ambulance to pick them
up um yeah who do this yeah um yeah come
here sir so you want me to get tasered
tasered by her chop SOI a little bit
with scars on my face hit with a bat I'm
okay Officer yeah I I survived that's so
stupid to think that hey well good thing
that you didn't you know use Force he
even told me that you did the right
thing by calling us to do our job and I
sat there and like do your job for what
it's out of your division because it's
an investigation report which one
division higher so it's out of you guys
can't do you guys can't [__] with it
it's it's it's it's the detectives and
detectives tell me I can't get a hold of
you and I look on the street they're
still there I'm like wow I told my lady
if I try to retaliate do anything stupid
or try to burn the trailer or the RV
it's called
arsonist who was the last one US you
might be here I'm might take off where's
your all man at arsonist for buring this
[__] down that's liable
for um bodily U human end danger of you
know killing individuals in in in in in
in RV or a trailer that's like Beyond
like you get charged for that big time
like dude so basically no one gives a
[__] about me when they try to attack me
and I survived but I'm okay but now you
want to and so my lady goes babe I go
you know what in my all my life it's
like when your time is your time and all
my testimonies I have been through of my
jaw being stabbed being drug by a
car how much more worse can it get and
say believe me it gets stupid worse when
you least expected it's like dude guy
with the summer starts wants to kill you
so bad and throws it at you want to have
it go through your throat and like and
then pull it out like and it squirts
then you die like that's a [__] up way
to go out but he couldn't kill you so
when you move it slices you the second
one if that sword would
went leave it alone leave it alone don't
don't don't pull it out if you pull it
out I'm going to die it's like a [__]
like damn and he got mad because he
couldn't kill you so what he had to take
off and bounce because oh [__] I'm in
trouble damn right you are so it's
like here I am still standing still
thank God
that you
know being sick and tired of being sick
and tired sometimes is just like you
know
what it's not how you handle situations
but you been you've been on the streets
most of your life most of my life yeah
because when I hit 21 I went to prison I
paroled when I was 38 17 straight damn
been out for nine years of my life
that's the longest I ever been out in my
life with two
strikes man you
know if I could be an example by sharing
my my experience with and Hope on
video and it goes Skyhigh
you ever think about you know doing
something positive to the new generation
they see you like wow wow hey he can do
it why can't I do it yeah I'm trying to
motivate the new generation that you
know hey it's not over yet homie you
know hey we fall down we get back up we
fall down we get back up but we don't
stay down we get up and we dust Stu off
and we keep pushing you don't think oh
it's over I can't do no no no no all
that soft [__] no knock it off man you
know J is can't Snoopy prison it molds
you
and it it it makes you to be a real
solado to you know hey survive the
fittest man every man from the south man
but you got to learn to you know it's
like sometimes I ask myself I'm just a
Onan person walking the streets of LA
but it seems to me that everywhere you
go oh who's that oh people stop I'm like
everyone else here man I'm like everyone
else man I ain't no better than he no
better than him I'm just like I'm bald
head whatever whatever but no it's like
beep beep move it like they're like
stuck on St like come on people for
reals man you know but my lady says
sometimes it's the attention that you
want the attention that you get I go
what if I'm not aing no attention what
I'm just to be just no just being me
well sometimes just being you [__] just
Falls right on you like you know and you
know as long as I don't have no [__] my
end where I have no guilty conscience
and go ahead officer handcuff me hey
babe I'll be back I'm gone no I don't
have [__] you know what I mean to this
day self- offense on my part need a
little more detail on that man cuz that
no no cuz uh she's injured he has a
crack skull yeah come with us that's
[__] up like damn you know so it's
okay for her to taser me and I'm still
alive pissing my pants and probably [__]
in my ass yeah I'm still good you know
what I mean but yet let her go and let
him live
it makes no sense it makes no sense and
like I said I I I
just things happen for a reason at the
right place at the right time or
sometimes at the wrong place at the
wrong time and I'm just you know like I
said I'm I'm thank God that I'm grateful
and I'm still breathing I'm still I'm
still alive and uh you got nine lives uh
past nine 10 uh 11 lives 11 past yeah
cuz the last video was uh I died uh 10
times and this one was a that's right
yeah so you think you'll be down here
the rest of your life
uh you could say for uh a quick pick or
a lucky scratcher oh my God I won other
than that you know what I mean it's like
you know how much more I'm going to work
my ass off or try to get SSI or you know
what I mean hope for a miracle but have
you ever had a real job uh I had a
Coleman construction job when I paroled
I went to IT Tech and got um SA Save the
Planet which is a contaminated
soil graduate and all we do is a New
Foundation being built has to be
inspected put the meters put the meters
the little testers beep this is hot soil
this is hot soil dumpsters come in Dig
It All Out test it again hot soil dig
deeper deeper and deeper to where you
walk into the compound a [__] Stadium
wa it's so [__] deep all that they
dug was all hot soil until the deepest
deepest okay we're good that's good soil
now a foundation of trucks come in with
bulldozers put in new soil and then put
the platform the foundation of the new
Metro system and they build it so in the
future the building that they buil if
anyone would to get hurt or you know
fall down or scrape their leg whatever
on contaminated soil later on the future
they have cancer it's like what the hell
CU yep when b u when um um Bowling
Heights and uh Compton East LA got the
chemical spill all over the compound on
the houses and everything they had to
come in test the house test the walls
test the uh countertops and yep
contaminate tear it down tear it down
and build a new Foundation it's like
damn little do they know that saving the
planet save the Earth is like
contaminated soil your kids can run
around play play play in the front yard
oh oh Mom I got hurt I got hurt I got a
little scrape oh you're okay little do
you know that little that little cut as
she's getting older goes get a little
test yeah I'm sorry yeah your daughter
has uh you know getting a process of
some cancer what the hell contaminated
soil man it's it's like they say it's
like Save the Planet by knowing your
surroundings and knowing that you're on
a good clean foundation not about oh
yeah this is contaminated this is yeah
this is okay but you can't be over here
but you be over here like what the hell
and when we had that kind of situation
we had to put on a full jumpsuit a full
white jumpsuit with um you know the the
the mask and
mountains of all contaminated soil put a
big old black trash B over it all the
way over it and then hope show yet other
projects this don't fly over there when
the wind comes it don't fly over there
or you know because it's you know uh
they could get charged and they could
get fined because it's you know it's
it's it's a federal
job it was a good job but the only thing
was I didn't have my own transportation
so I hey can I roll with you hey can I
roll with you oh I have somebody I I got
full car all right hey don't trip um we
got another job in La coming up pretty
soon man I'll give you a call they take
off up north and I'm like damn man what
can I say man you know I mean but uh
it's a damn good job it and I asked him
when I was working right here by six
feet Bridge hey how much am I be making
let's see uh eight hours a day Monday
through Friday from uh 7 to uh 7 to 3 he
goes uh he goes uh 52 I said 52 yeah is
that a problem I never made much I never
made that much of my life I made the
most in prison was 70 cents 70 cents in
all my life working every month every
month every month a 70 Cent check of a
month like
damn and so
52 I was like every week 1,500 1,500
1,500 damn for once I made some
hardworking money it's
clean and my mom tells you hey spend it
wisely or save your money I just came
out of prison I'm like happy I have all
this money I can buy this I can buy this
I buy this but in the relationships that
you're with it turns out that they end
up wanting too much now care about me
and I end up getting stabbed in the back
getting [__] over and it's just
another drama [__] that I have to
experience and say that hey I'm thankful
I'm alive and hopefully on the line I
can find someone that that true love or
that one that your Chemistry matches you
know and you know to this day her name's
Tweety and I thank God that you know
she's she's my everything man she's you
know she takes care of me she looks out
for me you know she has health issues of
you know
depression uh you know she has a you
know you know low self-esteem and you
know uh um uh what's it called where um
it gets real cold she's like neic and oh
I'm too cold like wow like damn are you
are you okay she I get I get cold real
easy so I got a little more extra to do
but other than that man you know I'm
just grateful and thankful that you know
I have someone in my life that you know
it's there for me and I thank God I'm
still alive and you like living in our
way to live in D Al yes I've been born
and raised in Al all my life since I was
a little kid and I love it and as as
expanding of New Foundations and new new
uh have you seen other parts of town
other than like the
hood as far as you tell me you went to
West Hollywood recently West Hollywood
oh my god when I went out there and said
Beverly Hills what were you doing in
West Hollywood that's where my boy he
lived over there in West Hollywood he
lived he lived on Seventh and Ford and
from Housing section 8 got moved to West
Hollywood and West Hollywood so the
housing put him there yeah but this
building he's in it's only music physic
uh music uh Physicians singers drummers
um um base base I mean keyboards
whatever you have to be a singer to live
in that 45 unit all singers singers
musicians keyboards drummers only live
in that building and myy boy was a
singer and he got to live in the first
floor way more bigger compound where he
lived in s in Stanford so small so tiny
now he's got a living room he's got a
kitchen he's got a big bathroom big old
bedroom I'm like bro here's a backyard
patio I go bro you got a ma he goes
don't I I said man patient does pay off
but where he lives up on a hill on Palm
going down s San to Santa Monica to P
once you come down that Hill you see
club club club club club like little
bamboo clubs little small little clubs
but oh my God West Hollywood the the the
flags are out okay the chi and's on the
D dancing like what the hell is going on
and I'm like Oh my like damn they're
dancing like hey what's up like oh [__]
all the G all the gay clubs are yeah
like I'm like okay I was like wa I was
like damn I'm he all the music and
there's guys and girls and I'm like wow
he goes hey my bro West Hollywood is
over here they can be who they want I'm
like whoa I mean nice clubs music and
everything clean it's a good Community
but I was like wow it was it was a trip
it was just seeing coming from the bike
from skit Road through Wilshire all the
way past West Lake MTA Park keep going
and then you Lear pits keep going BMW uh
uh uh Mercedes like what the hell all
these big old comp and the whole domino
just changes like whoa it's it's a trip
it's like damn it's like Beverly Hills
like oh my God I'm in the wrong
place but it's it's I'm thankful for him
to you know he has a nice liveable spot
and uh you know he's a good friend of
mine and he helps him out a lot and I
helped him out to get to where his new
location is and I mean man he has it
made man I'm like man blessings do come
around man so you know so other other
than getting stabbed you're you're doing
well other than that yeah other than
that you know just you know uh just one
day at a time and do it I'm very
thankful and you know just still hanging
in there man and thank God for
everything you know all right spooky
great seeing you again likewise man
thank you stay healthy always good luck
it
thanks